rococo tantôt merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur rt france comment vous
expliquez vous cette situation
l'explosion des appels pour dénoncer des
entorses aux règles du confinement
écoutez c'est un phénomène qu'on a
observé qui est assez important en
région parisienne mais aussi en province
pour exemple 70% des appels
police-secours bordeaux sont de ce type
d'appels à paris intra muros et en
région parisienne sept ans on constate
un phénomène un peu moins d'ailleurs le
préfet de police de paris a sorti une
note en expliquant qu' il fallait pas
encombré des lignes police secours
avec ce genre d'appel vous savez de tout
le temps dans toute crise sanitaire
économique
on a toujours eu ce genre d'appel bon
personnellement c'est un peu c'est un
peu les vides puisque vous avez beaucoup
de personnes qui appellent pour dénoncer
un enfant qui joue devant chez lui une
personne qui va emmener quatre fois
faire pisser ce gros chien
donc ce sont quand même des appels un
peu limite et je les condamne ou la
police nationale on a d'autres chats à
fouetter je vous rappelle que nature la
lutte contre la petite moyenne et grande
délinquance et aussi de travail
supplémentaire de faire respecter le
confinement en faisant les contrôles
donc on n'a pas de temps à perdre en
plus pour ce genre d'appel peut-être
qu'on peut comprendre aussi que les
enjeux sont quand même important avec
son confinement enjeu sanitaire mondiale
est-ce que vous qu'on peut comprendre
cette situation
bah on peut le comprendre et ne pas la
comprendre parce que ça peut aller très
vite vous savez on peut très vite aller
dans une dérive il suffit que d'ailleurs
60 plus de 70% des personnes qui
appellent pour dénoncer des personnes de
leur entourage ce sont des personnes
avec qui ils ont des conflits antérieurs
pour la plupart donc c'est un peu une
sorte de vengeance
et voilà je trouve ça moi un peu en ce
qui le concerne nauséabond et voilà le
maître mot c'est la communication
si vous avez un voisin qui respectent
pas le confinement vous allez le voir et
vous lui en parler alors il ya une
différence entre une personne qui va
faire un barbecue avec 35 personnes dans
son jardin d'accord la police va le cas
échéant se déplacer mais pour les autres
genre d'appel par exemple pour une
personne qui va emmener faire une vie
son chien trois fois dans la journée
voilà on va pas se dépasser de toute
manière il faut constater une flagrance
pour verbaliser
on ne peut pas vieille verbalise quand
ce qu'on constate une infraction on peut
pas faire un pv une verbalisation pour
une personne qui aurait n'aurait pas
respecté le confinement deux heures
avant on sait que les municipalités
avaient quand même demandé aux citoyens
de faire attention d'alerté même sur les
personnes qui ne respectent pas
forcément ce confinement c'est plus
qu'un maintenant oui tout à fait c'est
plus calme maintenant
et voilà surtout que je vous dis nous
travaillons en ce moment en mode dégradé
c'est à dire que vous avez beaucoup de
policiers qui sont en réserve
opérationnelle pour éviter nous-mêmes
d'être des lecteurs de la pandémie et
nous avons toujours la lutte contre la
délinquance qui est toujours actuelle
avec une recrudescence par exemple de
dégradations de véhicules puisque bon
les gens prennent de moins en moins leur
véhicule pendant le confinement et nous
sommes deux si on alerte par rapport à
ça et nous n'avons malheureusement pas
de temps à perdre pour répondre à voir
tous ces appels pour les secours qui je
vous le rappelle sont nombreux en pro
grâce et en région parisienne
ça vous dit pas de temps à perdre en ce
qui concerne
les forces de l'ordre on disait leurs
lignes sont sans saturer quels sont les
échos qui vous reviennent sur les
conditions dans lesquelles ses forces de
l'ordre
même leur mission aujourd'hui sur le
terrain notamment écouter les forces de
l'ordre et sont là et sont toujours
présentes vous avez constaté via la
presse et les médias que nous sommes
aussi confrontés à des violences dans
certaines zones de ré dans la région par
les aides là aussi en province
bon violences qui n'ont rien à voir avec
les notions même que nous avons connue
en 2005 habiller les belles mais tout de
même vous avez toujours une frange la
population minimes
heureusement qui est réfractaire au
confinement et qui s'est mise en marge
de la république et de l'état est notre
rôle aussi c'est de faire respecter le
confinement est de faire en sorte que
ces personnes là et bien reste chez elle
tout simplement merci beaucoup
rocco contento je rappelle que vous êtes
secrétaire départemental unité sgp
police à paris aussi à vous